well it's nice to see that everybody is
sort of recovering from Halloween
Halloween is actually a really
interesting holiday Halloween is when
people you don't know come to where you
live and take all your stuff
next up is Thanksgiving or is the Native
Americans call it Halloween
[Applause]
now now just because I said that it
doesn't mean I don't love the country I
love the country and you know how I know
I love the country I've never screamed
its name at a rally love is a quiet
emotion love doesn't engender screaming
people don't come home from the hospital
the fact is I've met far too many bald
men with ponytails to expect this world
to make sense
[Laughter]
so I've been waiting into reading the
newspapers again and I came across an
amazing this is absolutely true
having about three weeks ago in North
Carolina they had the big hurricane
there's a woman in her house her house
is filling up with water but she can't
go outside to get help because the water
outside the house was filled with snakes
and alligators now I'm not here to judge
anybody but if you're gonna drown in
your own home because the water outside
is filled with snakes and alligators you
did something
life is not that cruel
I'm sure the National Guard helicopter
go outside of a lower a ladder
I can't the water is filled with snakes
and alligators jeez lady what did you do
by the way why are there alligators like
I understand that God made sunsets and
rainbows do we really need a gorilla
made of leather that lives in the swamp
and wants you dead but then he come up
with a shark and think oh I can't chase
you across a golf course hang on I got
another idea then he came up with a
crocodile for the sole reason that you
could be thinking you're eaten by an
alligator and be wrong you know it's a
bad idea cuz it lives in the swamp
alligators crocodiles
what's a snake but a rope that hates you
put in the swamp just put in the swamp
the swamp is God's porn drawer all the
creepy stuff putting the swamp covered
with a t-shirt I'll deal with it later
don't worry about it so I'm walking down
the street with a friend of mine not to
brag
and he has a cellphone with him and he
pulls up a picture of a baby but from
like the forties like an old photo of a
baby because this isn't this a cute baby
like my god it's like the cutest baby
I've ever seen in my life
cuz yeah that's Charles Manson
my first thought was Oh screw that baby
wait I let that baby I kick it right in
the throat if I had a time machine I
would go back and get baby Hitler and
use him as a club to beat baby Manson to
death it would look weird in the moment
you'd get a crowd
you just have to explain it's okay these
are very evil babies making bad apples
into applesauce the end thank you very
much
[Applause]
you